[MUSIC]
>> I want you to stop for a second and
think about when I say customer
experience for you, what does that mean?
If you're anything like the students that
I normally see in class, what you think
about when customer experience is
literally the time in which the customer's
interact with whatever service person
you have in your organization.
That's the kind of answer that I typically
get when people think about customer
experience.
But then what I do is I ask people,
talk to me about your last vacation and
I want you to spend a minute and
think about your last vacation.
Describe to yourself and
sort of recreate in your mind
what that experience was like.
But when I ask them about their
experience of going on vacation,
they talk about planning the vacation,
anticipating the vacation, what they
do when they go on vacation and then
the memories that they have from vacation.
The customer experience is not simply the
very narrow interaction with your product.
It also includes a before and an after.
And those before and afters are critical
to how people understand your product, and
for your likelihood of achieving
the holy grail which is word of mouth.
So in psychology,
we talked about three sources of utility.
Utility is kind of like a measure
of psychological well-being.
More utility is something better.
Anticipated utility,
how much utility will I get?
Okay, I think about buying a car.
My experience with the car is
not just driving the car, but
it's also thinking about which car to buy.
Getting excited about that car.
Experienced utility, how much utility or
how much well being am I experiencing from
the actual use of the product itself?
Okay and this is typically when people
think about a customer experience,
they really focus on
the experience utility components.
Retrospective utility,
what do I remember this to be like?
And the memory is extremely important,
because the memory is what's going to
determine your word of mouth.
All three of those need to be
managed to create a really
truly winning customer experience.
Experiences aren't flat, right?
You don't sort of experience
the same thing at all times.
You have a moment of delight.
You have a moment of despair.
You have a moment of meh.
The way memory works is
in terms of snapshots.
I remember moments in that experience.
And why is that so critical, because it
tells you that what you need to manage is
not the film, but
it's specific kind of moments.
>> Understand how consumers experience and
rewire your approach to product strategy.
Learn more about
Innovative Product Leadership,
The Emerging Chief Product Officer.
[MUSIC]